good morning John one of the biggest
debates in climate change is whether we
should be talking about direct air
capture of carbon dioxide just taking
carbon dioxide out of ambient a seems
like a good idea my perspective is a
little weird on this I think that you
and I should not be talking about this
at the moment removing a pound of carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere is way more
expensive than just figuring out how to
not emit another pound of carbon dioxide
it's much easier to not emit it than it
is to capture it here is my absolute
favorite climate graph it shows so many
things all at once but you have to
understand it which is tricky on the
left is the amount of CO2 that is abated
that is either not emitted or removed it
starts at 5 gigatons which is the amount
of CO2 emitted by the US per year and
here's a question can you guess when it
is projected that that number will hit
its peak trick question it peaked in
2007 at 6 gigatons so like that's nice
no matter how many times I hear it this
number still surprises me 2007 6 gatons
is a full gigaton more than 5 gigatons
obviously though we still got a lot of
work to do we want the colored part of
this graph to get down not just to zero
but to below zero because the CO2 we
have already emitted does not just
disappear it's still there we need to
get rid of that stuff now the x-axis of
graph is often time but like scrub that
out of your head because in this case
the x-axis on the bottom is money it's
the dollar cost of a ton of carbon
dioxide abated either removed or not
emitted that number is like how big of a
climate premium are we willing to pay at
the current moment though and this is
kind of amazing the Mac curve and it's
called the ma curve by the way shows
that at a climate premium of $0 so just
doing what does not cost anything extra
that would take us all the way down to
3.75 gigatons per year the only reason
we haven't done that yet is because it
takes time and work to build the
infrastructure and you can see over on
the right hand side what exactly that
infrastructure would be to replace those
carbon emissions at a $50 per ton
premium we get down to below half of our
original CO2 emissions Peak but
something weird happens at 100 a lot of
things level off at that point you can't
squeeze much more abatement out of solar
or wind or EVS at that point a bunch of
other weirder stuff starts to make sense
like synthesizing zero carbon fuels or
hydrogen infrastructure and then
eventually All the Way Beyond the $200
per ton of CO2 mark it starts to make
sense to capture CO2 from the air that's
a lot of money per ton of CO2 like a
carbon tax of $250 per ton of CO2 would
break a lot of things I think people
would freak out but for $0 there's a lot
of good we can do right now and for $50
there's a lot of good we can do right
now so like let's focus on those things
right I recently visited a test facility
for a technology that captures carbon
dioxide from the air passively it's
called a mechanical tree and it's like a
tree and that it takes in carbon dioxide
but unlike a tree in that it's made of
metal and plastic and it takes in way
more CO2 than a tree but also it does
not turn that CO2 into anything else
like a tree turns it into tree it's
really quite cool basically the thing
extends ends upward and then all those
interior plates are exposed to the air
and depending on the amount of wind and
heat and moisture in the air the
material inside binds to CO2 at various
rates and then it's lowered back down
into the Container where the CO2 is
basically sucked off of the plates and
then pumped out then if this were
actually a commercial plant you'd need
to do something with that carbon dioxide
use energy to turn it into a fuel or
Pump It underground or make it like a
solid or something so it doesn't get
released back into the atmosphere this
is one of dozens of designs for
different ways to capture CO2 from the
air and all of them all of them are
entirely economically infeasible this
technology is at the baby stages right
now we can do an amazing amount of good
with zero climate premium and another
huge amount of good with just $50 per
ton of Premium but that Mac curve that I
showed you only shows things as they are
today right now the broader public focus
on direct air capture of carbon dioxide
would mostly be a distraction a lot of
people say we don't have to worry about
burning fossil fuels cuz we'll just
capture it with direct air capture but
that's silly because it's way more
expensive to do that than to just not
release the carbon in the first place so
my perspective is that you and I
shouldn't be thinking much about direct
air capture of CO2 because it's not what
needs to be implemented right now now
there are like physics reasons why
direct air capture is hard and expensive
the concentration in the air is low CO2
molecules are very stable and non-polar
so it's hard to get them to stick to
stuff but there are also reasons to
think that cost will come down if you
imagine imag in your brain the mat curve
extending out on a third axis this one
time you can imagine that the costs of
all of these things will come down and
everything will move over to the left as
time progresses but regardless of the
cost going down only so much good can be
done with more solar and wind and
electric vehicles So eventually the cost
of direct air capture is going to come
down and there won't be many other ways
to get the existing carbon dioxide out
of the atmosphere and suddenly it's
going to become important it's just
going to be a while before it becomes
important that's why these people are
working on it at the research phase
that's why the US government and private
companies are working with universities
to try and figure out the details of
this stuff now sometimes I feel like if
I'm personally not focusing on something
then it's not getting done but that's
not how the world works there are people
everywhere working to solve problems
sometimes in ways that are right in
front of our faces that we still don't
really need to pay attention to but it's
nice to pay attention to sometimes
nonetheless thanks very much to the
amazing guy from the center for negative
carbon emissions at Arizona State
University who responded to my text
message extremely quickly and showed me
around the facility just very very cool
ticket to do that John I'll see you on
Tuesday